So far.
We have been using
a generic UIViewController.
For a playback scene.
You had just set the generic
UIViewController's UIView.
To have a green background.
UIViewController is a great class.
But we cannot add any
code to it directly.
In order to do audio playback.
We need a UIViewController subclass.
That we can add our play by code to.
I'm going to show you how
to create this new class,
which we will call
the Play Sounds View Controller.
With the Pitch Perfect project open in
Xcode, let's choose File > New File.
Select Source under iOS,
and then Cocoa Touch Class.
Click Next.
For the class name,
let's call it PlaySoundsViewController.
Set it to be a subclass
of UIViewController, and
make sure,
also create NIB file is unchecked.
Even though it's written as XIB
we still call it a NIB file for
old historical purposes.
Make sure the language is Swift and
click next.
Here we can just make sure that
it's part of our project, and
that our project is selected as
the target and click create.
We can see our new
PlaySoundsViewController.swift file in
the project navigator.
There is one more step.
The storyboard does not know
we want to use this file for
the second view controller.
Let's walk through changing that.
Open the main doc storyboard, and
select the second view controller scene.
Be sure to click on the orange
view controller circle.
Open the inspectors panel by clicking
on the top right button here.
Select the identity inspector
as the third one from the left.
In the drop down for the class let's
select, play sounds view controller.
Press Return for it to take effect.
That's it.
Now storyboard knows to use our new
play sounds View Controller class
instead of just a generic
UI View Controller.